Digging for the truth is the name of the
game when it comes to True Detective,
but here are some secrets that even the most
diehard fans may not have uncovered yet.
Matthew McConaughey took his role
as one of the leading stars and
executive producers of the first
season of HBO's True Detective
seriously. Following McConaughey's powerful
performance in 2011's The Lincoln Lawyer,
show creator Nic Pizzolatto saw the potential for
McConaughey's involvement in the series as the
character Rustin Cohle, acting alongside
Woody Harrelson and Michelle Monaghan.
"I mean, it's like something's just got your name
on it, like a bullet, or a nail in the road."
Cohle is a complex character who could easily
alienate an audience with his nihilism and apathy,
so it was essential for McConaughey
to fully embody the deep pain of this
character. He arguably managed to do so by
extensively analyzing Cohle's identity to a
fundamental level. According to an interview
with Rolling Stone back in 2014, McConaughey
explained his need to create a document to chart
his character's life and growth over the 17 year
timeline depicted in Season 1. He broke Cohle's
essence down into four stages: 1995, Crash, 2002,
and 2012. Each section contained its own lengthy
analysis of the character's state of mind at
each time period. The result was a 450-page
graph titled Four Stages of Rustin Cohle.
It's common for many television shows not
to have multi-season arcs planned out from
the very beginning and — as a result — they can
lose direction. True Detective didn't have this
problem, as Pizzolatto always intended the
show to be an anthology with new casts and
stories every season, much like Ryan Murphy and
Brad Falchuk's FX series American Horror Story.
The strength of an anthology format comes from
creators exploring vastly different stories while
maintaining an overarching theme and tone.
While the characters and setting change,
each season follows the same basic format: two
detectives investigating crimes that lead to the
discovery of some wider conspiracy or mystery.
The second season cast Colin Farrell and Rachel
McAdams as their duo — with a notable performance
from Vince Vaughn as a career criminal — while
the third season had Mahershala Ali and Stephen
Dorff. However, in an interview with Entertainment
Weekly, Pizzolatto claimed that he initially
began writing the story that eventually became
Season 3 as a new project, only to realize
that it fit the themes of True Detective.
"I can understand your
frustration with the disease."
"A disease you can't even say what it is."
"We can say what it almost certainly is."
But the anthology format doesn't sit well
with all fans, with some missing the chemistry
between Harrelson and McConaughey, and Season 2
overall receiving lukewarm critical and audience
receptions. Although most fans and critics agree
that Season 3 was something of a return to form,
no matter how each season fares on their
own merits, the deliberate variation
provides fresh interest while preserving
Pizzolatto's dark, atmospheric style.
It hasn't always been smooth sailing for True
Detective. While the first season was hailed
as a towering achievement of episodic television,
the second and third seasons struggled to live up
to the hype. But one of the more troubling
developments for the show occurred during
production of the second season after
the departure of Cary Joji Fukunaga,
the first season's director. The hole left by this
major change forced HBO and Pizzolatto to search
for other artists to direct episodes throughout
the next season, and ended up splitting the load
between six different directors, which included
Justin Lin, Daniel Attias, and Miguel Sapochnik.
Some even bigger names were approached
early on but, for one reason or another,
they declined the offer to helm an episode.
The biggest of these filmmakers was horror icon
David Cronenberg, best known for creating classic
films such as Scanners, The Fly, and Videodrome.
According to Vulture, Cronenberg was
approached to direct, but refused, saying,
"...I thought that the script was
bad, so I didn't do it. In TV,
the director is just a traffic cop, but on the
other hand it is work and there's a lot of it."
What began as a working relationship between two
actors has reportedly grown into a deeply genuine
friendship between McConaughey and Harrelson.
The lead actors and executive producers on True
Detective played two diametrically opposing
partners who slowly grew to understand,
respect, and maybe even like each other
as the story unfolds. This combative
relationship between Rust Cohle and Marty
Hart was apparently difficult for them to
find when filming began because
of their existing relationship.
"Yeah, I didn't even know I'd hit him
the first time. He was like 'yeah,
good one. Yeah, nice one.'"
"Let me get this."
True Detective was not the first time these
two actors worked together, with them sharing
screen time in the lighthearted comedies EDtv
and Surfer, Dude. According to USA Today,
McConaughey and Harrelson had to focus on
breaking their existing off-screen dynamic so
that their characters could be appropriately
hostile to one another. Harrelson claimed,
"Not being on the same wavelength aided what it
was we were doing, but it was also uncomfortable."
True Detective doesn't shy away from
the grimmest aspects of true crime,
with every season's underlying themes
encompassing almost an otherworldly
evil. Season 1 heavily references aspects of
occultism behind the murders at the show's center,
with creator Nic Pizzolatto directly
referencing horror author Robert W.
Chambers' book The King in Yellow to create
the series' eerie atmosphere and plot.
Some key terms and phrases from this relatively
obscure piece of 19th-century supernatural horror
are peppered throughout the first season, with
the unknown killer Rust and Marty hunts known as
the Yellow King, who lives in a dark place called
Carcosa. These are lifted directly from the novel
about the evil entity known as The King in Yellow,
as well as a lost city named Carcosa — itself
borrowed from an even older short story by seminal
American author Ambrose Bierce. But Chambers was
also a strong admirer of H.P. Lovecraft, so
his work was heavily infused with a similar
sense of cosmic dread. This, in turn, inspired
Pizzolatto during his series' development.
In an interview with EW, Pizzolatto directly
addressed how the horror elements of Chambers'
book changed his writing process, claiming,
"When I did that, a kind of secondary
language began to form in the scripts,
where the notion of cosmic horror became
a very real part of the environment."
While most television shows and movies are
filmed and presented digitally these days,
some notable exceptions continue to opt for
old-school film. Acclaimed filmmakers like
Quentin Tarantino, Martin Scorsese, and
Christopher Nolan all eschew digital in
favor of film. According to an interview
with Cinemablend, Tarantino claimed,
"If you're not doing the work to get a great shot,
then what's the point? Digital cinematography
puts all the heavy work in the post-production
rather than planning and attempting
to get the perfect shot while on set."
Fukunaga and cinematographer Adam Arkapaw
chose to shoot on 35mm film for all eight
episodes of Season 1, which made it
much more difficult to get some of
the more complex shots in the show.
Unfortunately, it looks like this may
exclude that famous six-minute tracking
shot in the episode "Who Goes There?"
"Come out with your hands raised!"
"Get down on your knees!"
During an interview with Variety,
Arkapaw touched on the challenge of
filming a show this way. He said,
"In a film, you might be accustomed to shooting
two to three minutes of screen time a day. On
True Detective, we were shooting five
to six minutes every day. Basically,
your time to devise, prepare and
execute your work is cut in half."
Many fans and critics agree that
the extra effort was worth it,
with Season 1's visual richness being a big
part of its overall appeal. Sadly — according
to PremiumBeat — subsequent seasons
weren't so lucky and were shot digitally.
The second season of True Detective brought
in an entirely new cast of characters in a
completely different location, with arguably mixed
results. While critics didn't seem to appreciate
the supposed decline in writing and story, they
acknowledged the strong leading performances of
the many cops and crooks operating in Los Angeles.
This included Rachel McAdams as Ani Bezzerides,
Vince Vaughn as Frank Semyon, and Taylor Kitsch
as Paul Woodrugh. But the actor who seemed to
make the most waves among the cast was
Colin Farrell as Ray Velcoro — a dirty
cop torn between his desire to do the
right thing and his criminal loyalties.
"I remember you dumping a body."
"The reasons for all this, all that,
might not exist for me anymore."
Farrell has had a long and eclectic career,
playing a wide array of characters in movies
like In Bruges, Fantastic Beasts and Where
to Find Them, and The Batman. At the time
he was added to the True Detective cast, he
was most often known for playing comedic,
charming rogues. But after being cast
as the alcoholic, deadbeat detective,
Farrell had to change his body to match.
According to ET, the actor gained roughly
20 pounds prior to filming and hated
every second of it. Farrell claimed,
"People think it must be fun to
eat what you want — and it is,
for the first day  Day
two, when you're already on
your second cheeseburger and fries with a
chocolate shake by 11 a.m., not so much."
Given the success of Season 1, many
thought that Pizzolatto's writing
and Fukunaga's directing were a
match made in heaven. However,
the pair reportedly didn't get along well
during production. In the past few years,
Fukunaga has gone on record explaining how the
working partnership between him and Pizzolatto
deteriorated as the show went on. During an
interview with The Hollywood Reporter, he claimed,
"Over the course of the project,
Nic kept positioning himself as if he was
my boss and I was like, 'But you're not my
boss. We're partners. We collaborate.'
By the time they got to postproduction,
people like [former HBO programming president]
Michael Lombardo were giving Nic more power.
It was disheartening because it didn't
feel like the partnership was fair."
It seems that this tension was one of the
reasons Fukunaga did not return for season
two or three of True Detective, though he did
retain his role and credit as executive producer.
Some claim that one of the unsung heroes of
True Detective is actress Alexandra Daddario
as the character Lisa, a court stenographer and
Marty Hart's mistress in 1995. While Lisa and
Marty's secret affair becomes increasingly
toxic, Daddario brings genuine empathy,
complexity, and depth to a character who easily
could have been written off as superficial.
"Go away. I'll call the cops."
"Well, let's see how that works out for you."
"I know other cops."
"OK."
"Get out!"
However, her character being highly sexualized led
to Daddario's apprehension about filming
her first-ever nude scenes for the show.
According to a 2014 interview with MTV,
the actress explained just how difficult
it was to prepare herself for her scene,
"I really wanted to be part of the show,
and I understood why the nudity and all
of that was required of the character
The character is really different
from anything that I've done before.
The nudity was just part of that."
Fortunately, Daddario claimed that the
cast and crew helped put her at ease,
with Harrelson in particular making the
whole interaction very comfortable for her.
Although it's hard now to imagine
Rust Cohle played by anyone else,
it turns out that the casting was originally going
to be flipped, with McConaughey slated to play
Marty instead. At this time, McConaughey
was mainly known for his comedic roles,
going all the way back to his breakthrough
role in Richard Linklater's Dazed and
Confused. While he'd already branched
further out with more serious roles,
he was still seen as a jovial performer who would
fit better as the more light-hearted Marty Hart.
During an interview with WNYC in
2014, McConaughey talked about
his experience being brought in by HBO to read
for Marty. While he was intrigued by the show,
it was actually Rust Cohle's dialogue
that piqued his interest. He said,
"The guy I can't wait to hear what comes out of
his mouth every time I turn the
page is this guy Rustin Cohle."
Once McConaughey realized how badly he
wanted to play Rust instead of Marty,
he apparently laid it out
to the showrunners, saying,
"I read the first two episodes and said, 'Look,
I like the role of Cohle. If you guys are
interested in me for the role, I'm in.'"
He was ultimately right, considering his
performance in True Detective received some
of the highest praise he's ever gotten from
audiences and critics throughout his career.